after leaks denials flat-out lies and
escapes to Russia the NSA surveillance
program has finally been reined in a bit
Obama just signed the USA Freedom Act
which is being touted as the most
important surveillance reform bill in a
generation
so is it I consider it a milestone
because it is so rare and unusual for
our political process to produce any
output that goes back and the
surveillance there it's almost always
expanding it the USA Freedom Act puts an
end to bulk collection of our phone
records and in six months the NSA has to
stop doing so the USA Freedom Act also
says telephone companies will hold on to
records and government agencies will
have to get a court order from a secret
federal court to get an individual's
data remember before under Section 215
of the Patriot Act the NSA would simply
collect everyone's data and then try to
find a needle in a haystack every 90
days they'd go back to the FISA Court to
ask for renewed permission to sweep up
more data but section 215 along with two
other sections of the Patriot Act just
expired and thanks in part to Senator
Rand Paul the human wrench in Congress's
weal Americans went unmonitored for two
whole days but then came the USA Freedom
Act which renewed roving wiretaps and
the lone wolf provision but changed up
to 15 so yes the feds can still get your
information if they really want it but
they can't just snatch up everyone's at
the same time the data buffet is closed
but won't the FISA Court just be flooded
with more requests and dole out the
approvals perhaps but the new law
requires the court to be more
transparent disclosing more about what's
going on and provide privacy advocates
for any large requests but the USA
Freedom Act does have loopholes section
702 of the FISA Amendment Act a new
leaked by Edward Snowden revealed that
under 702
FBI and the NSA can now spy on anyone
deemed a cybersecurity threat even if
they're not tied to a foreign government
all without a warrant also under section
702 the prism program that collects our
internet data which let's be real
totally Dwarfs phone call data and
warrantless surveillance of non
Americans and anyone communicating with
them got family overseas then there's
executive ordered twelve triple three a
secretive decree that the NSA uses to
justify digital surveillance worldwide
oh boy as Elizabeth going teen of the
Brennan Center for Justice says about
privacy in the u.s. this is a fight for
the ages and this is really just the
first round guest privacy advocates
can't take the gloves off just yet